[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks lovely to have you joining us
and welcome home
to the battlefield what a week it's been
for all of us
you now know what we know that the
all-out warfare of battlefield is headed
to 2042.
so stick around with me freeman hello
and some of the gang from across dice
we're here with you for the next while
while we look back at everything that
we've revealed this past week
now to keep things as safe and
responsible as possible
we are pre-taping this live stream so
that we can spend as much time as we can
talking with you and taking you behind
the scenes but please do say hello in
the chat
we're all watching live along with you
from our homes
so starting us off i'm here with oscar
gabriel son
and daniel berlin design director for
2042.
it's lovely to see the both of you i
mean oscar you're looking resplendent
but look we've had a year working from
home right and you can use that time in
different ways one of course to build an
amazing battlefield 24 2 but you can
also
experiment with beards and you know
exotic haircuts but
daniel and i have agreed as we reach our
next big milestone i can finally drop
this thing so we just need to hurry a
bit that milestone right and then we
should be all good
back to normal no pressure daniel no
pressure at all
so let's get started then 2042 a brand
new setting
yes for battlefield this is exciting
what
got us to this era yeah it's actually
one of those moments i remember
quite dearly so i think it must have
been three years ago now um yeah we kind
of headed up on the 11th floor of dice
and we're actually supposed to look at
the concepts for this next pelvic game
and this time around the team went quite
wide i think we looked at 12 different
concepts or so
some really unconventional things some
that took us back in time some some
things that took us into the future we
looked at drippamatics and you know a
lot of concepts
and then we got to this thing that we
called 2042. and we all looked at that
you know piece
and kind of looked around the room and
we just kind of felt it in here
we found it it was this kind of special
moment of taking
the best pieces about the three and four
that notion of like modern warfare
and then spicing it up a bit with
cutting edge hardware and some of that
we've seen in the last couple of days of
course
yeah another big thing for us as well
this
is the first battlefield in many years
for us where we're putting full
focus on multiplayer yeah i mean it's a
big one for us i mean multiplayer is
what we do best and we've done best
across now the two decades the
battlefield has existed so you know in
battlefield 2042
three core experiences of course now
we've talked about all-out warfare we're
going to be
bring back conquest and breakthrough on
a bigger scale than ever
128 players some pretty cool big land
masses to play on
and then we have more to update on as we
get to ea play as well yeah because
there really is so much more
to this journey that we'll be sharing
with all of you
um let's get into the absolute
nitty-gritty of
things though um daniel big changes to
conquest
as oscar mentioned big focus for us in
this first section
yeah but conquest has had some
significant changes to meet this
big new scale that we have for 2042.
yeah for sure i mean this has been
it is a leap for us right and when we go
to
128 players when you go to a larger
play space you can't just kind of copy
what we've done before we had to also
kind of reinvent how we approach level
design and how we approach pacing in the
game
so what we're doing this time around to
really encapsulate
still the essence of battlefield and the
pacing um
that our players know and love is that
we're introducing this concept
that we're calling clusters while
watching the the gameplay reveal for
example we have this map
called hourglass which is set in qatar
which is
really really awesome and um this map
really speaks to the new mentality
around
the level design i think um and the
clustering because you can
almost imagine it as a massive
battlefield but within that
massive battlefield there there's almost
multiple battles going on
if you go to the western part of this
map you'll find a
huge stadium and within the stadium
itself there's
multiple capture points and if you want
to own
the entirety of the stadium that entire
sector you have to actually fight and
control
all of the capture points within that
sector when to capture the entirety of
the stadium
but then you can so imagine that you're
in there with your virtue squad and
you're you're engaged in a
close quarter combat situation and it's
quite hectic and then
you manage to win you capture the
objectives in the state and you go like
okay
now it's a little pause right um then
you run outside of stadium when you open
up your maps and go like okay where are
we going next guys
we see that they're capturing the neon
city on the far end of the map
and then you go like okay we got to get
there so you bring up your your colon
tablet
you say like okay with your transport
vehicle i need it over there it comes
down with a parachute
lands in front of you your squad hops in
and then you have a
a traversal as you travel to this other
sector
which is a sector full of skyscrapers
where you can zip line between the roofs
or the skyscrapers as you fight for
multiple skyscrapers
so it's this concept of clustering
objectives into
concentrated areas where we can have
high pacing
but then also having different types of
gameplay in these
and in between these spaces as well you
have
um vast open landscape on the hourglass
map for example the rolling sand dunes
and it's really cool
for people that really love vehicle
gameplay to be engaged in vehicle on
vehicle
type of combat in between these clusters
but there's of course also within the
level design
areas of our maps that is is built for
the infantry and
um vehicle mix and in hourglass there's
a perfect spot for this if you go down
south
of the map there's actually a quite
sizeable village down there
which has interior for infantry but the
vehicles can also roam the streets there
is a really good match up in there
and in the center of the map there you
have these massive arches that is
overlooking this highway intersection
where this massive convoy has run to a
stop and there's lots of
uh vehicles that have been abandoned and
stuff like that so
lots of stuff is happening with conquest
uh and with the level design in order to
really bring out the the
scale and the uh for us to really infuse
more
battlefield moments and uh just sandbox
about gameplay a lot of this new
approach for us with clustering is very
much inspired by the success we've had
in maps in the past like goldman railway
we're chatting about earlier on and
sinai desert with the village that you
kind of have there as well perfect
example
this where a lot of that kind of comes
from for you in the team we kind of
tested the concepts a couple of years
ago with those games
um but now we're kind of taking that
concept and when we're taking it to the
max
basically so um it's it's it's been
really fun for us to kind of
test around these different types of
setups and landing on something that we
really like
but i think it's important to mention
with conquest that like the freedom and
access to the sandbox is
literally at your fingertips do you need
a vehicle okay call them tablet get it
to get it in here
do you want to change out your um your
customization on your weapon hey the
plus menu just
change it out on the fly you don't have
to respawn or anything like that and the
freedom of choice
hey i want to have close quarters i go
to the stadium hey i want to have some
awesome crazy verticality
i go to the neon city i want to have you
know vehicle on vehicle gameplay let's
roam the fields in between
but then we have breakthrough spell
rights in 2042 we
we're more separating the experiences
and making them more distinct and
leaning into the strengths of them
to a higher degree i would say so while
you have this what we call varied pacing
in conquest where you know you have
those high octane
combat situation in the in in the in the
stadium and then the pacing goes down
and then you call your vehicle and then
you travel you talk and you strategize
you should be attacked in your city from
the south
from from the west in breakthrough it's
more like we take
128 players and it's two teams the
defender
and the attacker and we compress them
down to a smaller space we say like now
you're gonna fight in this sector only
so breakthrough is this experience where
you go on this journey throughout the
map
um but it's it's just short time to
action
it's just chaotic and crazy but we're
still leaning into the size here as well
we wanted to give you more tactical
opportunity when you're playing
breakthrough than we've necessarily done
in the past
um so we still use the width of the map
to a large extent so you if you find
yourself
spawning running forwards just like up
there's a meat grinder in front of me
lots of people dying here lots of things
going on we're not going to give you
ample space to flank around and then
take other strategic opportunities as
well
yeah and it's it really is exciting so
many of the battlefield fans that i've
been chatting to
since we revealed the game and then
showed off gameplay last week at xbox
um they are really excited at these
changes but then of course there's so
many new players
who suddenly are really excited to find
out what this is and
i think one of the best new things that
we're really adding is that we're
creating
kind of new ways for people to get into
the experience with our use of ai
yeah i mean ai has been one of those
things that we've been kind of you know
cooking back at the eyes for many years
and battlefield 24 2 is kind of the
perfect timing with next-gen tech to
introduce it
so in battlefield 24 2 you can actually
kick off the game
and play solo with ai squad members on a
whole big team with ai members facing ai
and that's just a great way to kind of
learn the basics of the game you know
mastering weapons understanding how the
vehicles and gadgets work
and kind of from there then graduating
into a mix of both
both with like real humans in pvp and ai
it's just a really good way for us to
onboard new players but actually even in
regions where sometimes we don't have
enough players online on the servers
we'll just fill that up with ai
until everyone comes online and we can
have those servers full with only valve
in mayhem 24 7.
so it's pretty cool um going back to the
maps daniel
um they're big we've obviously been able
to show off
one of them uh with hourglass in the
trailer this past weekend
but just in general like to help
conceptualize it for people
just how big are they so like when we
give these past references to some of
our older maps which are quite big now
we're 128 players like
how much of a scale increase have we
gone for on some of our maps
there's not there's not like a general
number we said like okay they need to be
two times or they need to be four times
or something like that we
we just for same it's kind of staying
true to the formula battlefield
in the sense that some maps are smaller
than others but
um across the board things have
increased in size
because this is the nature of having 128
players and needing to kind of
accommodate for that in terms of pacing
so it has grown
in size but we still have maps that are
um uh
smaller than hourglass for example is
one of the bigger ones we have it's i
think it's the second biggest one
uh next to irreversible which is the the
biggest one we built and i think that
one is
5.9 square kilometers which is
quite insane but again in that map
when you go there uh we will have the
same mentality of the
uh like the clustering so if you want to
have
um the example you gave freeman with uh
sinai desert with the town it's like
if you go into reversible there is a
placer called the
um the the oil ports which is a
really big um industrial space with
silos
and also uh barracks for for for workers
to live in in
different types of industrial buildings
and stuff where you can still get
um that really high octane battle and
over to the side there's also a big oil
rig which has a lot of close quarter
combat so
it's that concept of choosing where you
want to fight in this massive battle
basically and of those maps obviously
we've mentioned two of them there
hourglass and then irreversible but
we're we're launching with
seven for our all-out warfare part of
the game like
oscar which so far have you found to be
the absolute coolest
i just i have to say kaleidoscope again
i'm a big kind of secret shanghai fan
from bf4 but claricoscope is kind of
that but on steroids
uh you know with both the wingsuit that
we're introducing in the game
the grappling hook that mckay uses and
the zip lines there's just some like
awesome
you know gameplay that emerges from all
of that when players are like flying
between skyscrapers
right left and center must be one of the
favorites how about yourself
yeah that is i mean it's a i also love
urban settings in that sense
uh it gives you that kind of almost like
heat
feeling when you're running on the city
streets and ducking behind cars
you know cars are the best covers in
video games ever they just break in fun
ways
so they're awesome to hide behind um and
of course you know having multiple
skyscrapers having you know up in the
penthouse of the skyscrapers and
fighting another squad that is in
another penthouse and zip lining in
between
that's super cool um but yeah i mean my
favorite
i like hourglass a lot when we saw in
the gameplay review i just love
the stadium and the neon city and the
town to the south and the arches in the
middle
and the rolling standards in between i
think that's just so cool
because there's so much variety in there
you know you can really choose how you
want to play
um but yeah no that will have to say
that one i don't know maybe the orbital
is pretty nice orbital just waiting for
the rocket launch there's this like
perfect space you can stand on and like
to see the rockets hopefully no one
shoots you when you're watching the
thing because it's quite spectacular
yeah that's a favorite that is
definitely a favorite i like that a lot
i like the big open space in
front of the rocket which is kind of
like a a space where you can move in
between for a lot of vehicles to do but
the infantry can move to the sides
around it and go from for building to
building to building
but also has a really cool other aspect
because you have the launch site
over here but on the other side of the
hill in the mountain you actually have a
cryo facility
and you can choose to like take the
roads or you can choose to kind of just
run across the mountain if you want to
but there's also a massive tunnel that
goes through and i've been in some play
tests where it's just okay we captured
you know the uh the rocket facility now
let's head down to the crowd plan
and we we get into a transport vehicle
and we hop in and we start going in that
tunnel
just like no no and then obviously you
go from a turn it's just like in one of
the places i
was facing two enemy tanks and i was
like oh yeah that's it and then
boom i'm gone yeah um so that tunnel is
really cool
it's just a lot of cool moments and a
lot of and a lot of the the the gameplay
spaces we built it's difficult to choose
which one is the
it's the the favorite to be honest i
mean it really is the most common thing
though because i ask this question of
everyone
across the studio and it's it's always
the same every week because we get to
play tests
and we work through all of the different
maps every week we discover something
new that we love about these new ones
it's so cool um of these maps though of
course that
they're more than just maps they're very
dynamic in their nature of them we we've
obviously took a lot of inspiration from
our past and
looked you know now very much at the new
technology offered to us by frostbite
and the upgrades that we've done on all
our engines these worlds are a lot more
dynamic now oscar
yeah i mean we've worked for a good
three years now on some of these new
weather and evolution systems um i
remember in that first pitch when we
talked about the game
maybe it was daniel maybe with someone
else on the sign team said like wouldn't
be
cool if we could throw like a real-time
tornado onto the battlefield that could
turn
everything kind of upside down and cause
massive destruction and i think
everyone's sitting there kind of nodding
we looked over at the tech team and
they're like
are we supposed to make this work uh and
then kind of a year later we have that
first prototype
and i remember us showing it to other
team members like okay but that's
pre-rendered right just has to be fake
can't look that like that and we're like
yep
it works and i think you know it started
with you know being a thing that would
run like spectacle on the maps in
massive ways
but now it's kind of one of the core
gameplay drivers as well i mean you can
actually use those that big tornado to
your advantage
especially if you strap on that wing
suit just to kind of escape crazy
situations
uh there's just more of that and then on
hourglass of course standstorm pretty
epic performance yeah there's a massive
sense from a
huge wall of sound that also passes by i
think
one of the things that i really love
about you know the tornado is like just
physics are fun in games right and this
is a big
kind of like physics entity just moving
across
this the map and you don't know where
it's going to go it doesn't go in the
same path every time
you don't even know if it's going to
show up to be honest and it just causes
a lot of those you know
unexpected fun physics
moments where there's this the the the
scenario i described in the in the event
where i'm just like i'm running
that was on orbital um and i was running
from the rocket towards the rocket
assembly building
across that big open space and of course
i was stupid
so i was just like i can run that no
problem so i started running
and then you know i guess they just
started running and then i just heard
this
the shots are coming back like of course
i mean i'm stupid
and i look over you know and there's
there's a there's a sniper
he's not in a building it's actually
sitting on a little knoll over there um
and he's taking shots at me and i'm just
like oh well this is over i mean i'm
just gonna start to zigzag and do my
stuff and try to survive
but the storm is actually somewhere else
right now but
it's it happened to have picked up a
transport vehicle and flung it up and
then it had
flung it across the map so i'm just
running there and all of a sudden you'll
see like
and he just lands on the sniper and he's
like yes that's because that's the fun
unexpected things when you introduce a
lot of physics and
into this into a sandbox environment so
i think it's such a
great addition to the sandbox and that's
really what we want with
um 2042 in its essence you know infuse
the game with
lots of new tools and did you know the
tools that are modern that are
cutting edge technology and also just
push that in there and let players have
a lot of fun with them combining things
and doing that stuff that's the
that's the secret sauce i think and it's
not just the big flashy things either
there's lots of just small interactions
we've built back into our levels now
yeah to give players
much more agency as they kind of move
about the space yeah there's definitely
there's
we had those in battlefield 4 as well um
but we've expanded the roster there so
you
you know things like hey i'm holding
this uh this checkpoint and i see that
there's we're playing breakthrough for
example and i see there's tanks coming
at us it's like i'm going to raise the
bollards
so they would have to have a teammate
actually leave the tank or have someone
else come in and
raise lower them for you to be able to
to pass through and actually get to the
capture point
and i mean we mentioned all the zip
lines there are different types of gates
and doors that you can lock down
um there's bridges that you can uh race
that you can lower on
on kaleidoscope for example so um we
really
leaned into the dynamic nature of
the space and make it feel like you can
interact and you can counter
different type oh there's an attack
coming oh i'm gonna you know i'm gonna
raise the bridge so now their vehicles
can actually pass
and stuff like that so um i think the
team has done a really great job with
that stuff
yeah um that's the world then that 2042
takes place in but if that's the world
that we're playing with what about the
things that we're actually
playing with in those worlds so weapons
gadgets vehicles we've made some pretty
big changes
for 2042 the biggest of which that
people have been chatting about is
specialists
and how that's kind of integrating with
what we've done uh
in terms of roles in the past so daniel
how how are the specialists fitting into
this
world so the specialists are so let's
take a step back i think first because
we we looked at this for quite some time
in terms of what we wanted to do here
and we looked at a lot of player data
we looked at feedback and we looked into
like the internal sentiment
and there was a lot of things we can
also see for the data specifically that
a lot of players chose their class based
on the
the primary weapon that was available
meaning you wouldn't
you didn't choose necessarily a recon
because of the gadgetry but you actually
chose a recon because you got the
bolt-action sniper rifles
and you didn't choose your class because
you wanted to play a certain role
so that was the thing we wanted to kind
of target with this change specifically
we wanted to bring the game into a space
and when you choose which specialist to
play with you go like okay
i want to play this particular role so
what we've done is that basically you
have what we did the traditional class
say
recon is more of a category now and
underneath that category
you have multiple specialists that that
that have has a gameplay role that is a
recon gameplay role
but what we're also doing to kind of um
to
to bring this even further in terms of
unlocking the sandbox
is that we're saying that take casper
for example he's a recon type of
specialist
his particular gadget that he uses that
only he can use
is to recon drone but aside from the
recon drone casper can bring
a shotgun a sniper rifle an smg
an lmg whatever you want to put on
casper you can put on casper you can put
a rocket launcher on casper to to to to
couple with the
uh the recon drone you can put as a
throwable you can equip him with c4
so we get away from that space as well
where as we kind of seen in previous
games where
on certain maps that were vehicle heavy
you just saw pretty much one class being
played the one that can counter vehicles
but now you choose your gameplay role
and then we have a a
whole array of open gadgetry that you
can just freely choose from
so we see a better diversity in terms of
gameplay styles
across all our maps when we're playing
the game okay and we talked about casper
there we showed three other
of our specialists off in the past week
we've got fork mckay
and boris your favorite of the bunch oh
yeah i always get into too much trouble
i'm i'm way too aggressive about the
players so the grappling hook with mckay
helps a whole lot but there's something
special right with falc as well
um you know getting the opportunity to
revive teammates you know from afar it
creates these really unexpected moments
we're like i can actually help that guy
i think he should the other guy in the
back you're like like it's never feel it
felt so great to actually revive a
person that kind of really helped the
team move forward
yeah no [ __ ] is really good um i think
that's going to be a really favorite
favorite type of specialist for people
that were really into
um medic type of gameplay
class category and we're we're kind of
categorizing support as
a character that uh supports
the teammates through you know ammo
distribution
uh or through reviving or healing so
there's multiple characters within
the support category um folk
specifically has the pistol saret
like oscar mentioned so she can heal you
at a distance but she can also revive
you at a distance
and she also has a particular trait to
combat surgeon
which means that when she does revive
you she brings you back to full
health which is something if someone
else survived another type of specialist
revives you
they won't bring you back to full health
so it really leans into that
particular role even stronger and
pushing up
yeah of course we have boris as well
it's fulfilling an engineer role for us
first time we've had that engineer roll
back in quite some time yeah for sure
so uh boris is is a really cool guy um
he has the uh the sentry system as his
particular uh
gadget and this is a center system that
boards can place down
and it will acquire targets and support
you uh with support of fire
but the key is here is that the trait
that that boris has
means that he needs to be close to the
century for it to be able to
uh actually be as effective as it can be
and it's it's also quite of a um a
squishy
um gadget in that sense
because it's a perfect thing for someone
like kasper for example
who sits at a distance uh with his recon
drone because the recon drone can also
fire darts of emp
so he can actually fly over with his his
recon done is shoot darts at the
at the turret and take it out instantly
because it's weak against emp it's also
weak against um
uh explosions so there's always that you
know rock paper scissor counter game
play
taken into consideration when we're
building all these things yeah
so that's our specialists and plenty
more specialists to show you guys
before we get to launch too but let's
talk about the weapons
um i mean we've got a great selection of
weapons already in the game but there's
a very significant gameplay change that
we
kind of likely touched on earlier on
people would have seen it for the first
time
during our gameplay reveal this past
weekend
um the plus menu yeah this is huge
it is it's one of those things where
particularly this thing i'd say it was
one of those things that like you know
from already from a conceptual state
when it was on paper and just did you
know conceptual markups of it it was
just like ooh this is pretty sweet
uh and then once it actually went into
the game it was
we didn't so sometimes certain features
you have to iterate on them
you know to get to a place who's like ah
that's where it goes but this one was
just
it was just there and we did we also
done external feedback on it
and we've done internal feedback on it
and the the the general output
is like it feels like this is something
that has always been here
and it should have always been here it
doesn't it feels like something that
should we should have done it long time
ago almost
um but in general it means that like
you're running around and you find
yourself in a
in a situation you didn't expect
yourself to find yourself in which is
battlefield in a nutshell
uh i ran around the corner and she was
like oh okay this now i'm in this space
and i didn't that's not what i spawned
with
so how do i counter that do i respawn
it's like no
you can you can actually just take up
your weapon in front of you change out
the barrel
change out the the underbarrel
attachment you can change that to scope
um and you can change out the ammo type
so you kind of change the way it plays
completely
um but there is still a range in terms
of
balance here for example which is
important to to call
out i think um and that's like you can't
have a
smg and turn it into a sniper rifle you
know an smg still sits within it's it's
it's
it's category of usage but it can it can
it can deviate slightly to either
to either side right so the the plus
system is not going to be removing the
the the need for weapon archetypes we
just make each weapon archetype
somewhat more um wide in its usage in
that sense
and i'd say that there's a red thread
that goes through the whole game i kind
of
then we we decided this early on in the
game vision right this notion like
adaptability for players given like
everything that's happening on the
balcony we need to give the players you
know the
optimal amount of choices in real time
so plus menu is uh you know an example
of that
the call-in systems you can kind of drop
in vehicles they kind of at any time
but also that choice with the
specialists you know giving them the
option to use any primary weapon or open
gadget they wish
yeah and like just unlock loads of
sandbox moments like in past battlefield
games you were kind of stuck to be
honest
and the only way to kind of change your
gear was actually more or less to
redeploy yeah
and now you're taking these kind of
real-time time decisions just creating a
whole bunch of new mayhem right so it's
a lot of fun
and one of the best ways to take out a
sniper if you don't have a car being
flung by a tornado for you but that's a
good thing though that's a good thing
but it doesn't happen every time
uh it's it's like if you see this
happens now in the play test by the way
uh so if if there's a sniper laying on a
hill somewhere
and there's a certain range which you
can call in
um the vehicles you can't come forward
but if you're within a certain range you
can actually call in
a tank that lands on them so it's a good
way to take out that sniper
so he doesn't even know and i'll like
he's just laying there proning and
sniping all of a sudden i called in a
tank that just lands on his head and
kills him
that's pretty fun there's so many
gadgets as well to play around with i
mean oscar you mentioned there we now
have
we have open gadgets but of course we've
also got our class gadgets as well
but they really do amp up the sandbox
nature of the gameplay
now so each specialist has its um the
guidance that is connected to to them
specifically
and then we have the bucket of open
gadgetry and the open gadgetry bucket is
is
is very varied and diverse
um and it means that you can stick with
a specialist and still
you know be eligible in every situation
you find yourself in because you can
always
okay i'm gonna be in this part of the
map where there's a lot of vehicles i
can decide
to to equip um some gather tree that is
that is good for fighting vehicles even
if i'm playing with say
[ __ ] that where my primary role is is
healing i can still be a healer
in a combat situation that involves
vehicles and still be viable
and that's something that is um that is
new for battlefield and it's something
that i think we needed
yeah and the vehicles too we've i mean
not only have we just brought back some
favorites you know
the little birds back yes we love to see
it
um but we've also took a really good
look at
the way in which we approach vehicles
because i think for some vehicles
are a means to an end you get in them
you fly from one point to another we've
tried to
focus more on what it is that all people
are doing in a vehicle when you're
actually using them
yeah there was there was a notion in the
beginning of the project where we said
we want vehicles to be platforms for
team play so
um we wanted to be enablers of great
team play and they've been so
in the past i think but we just kind of
touched upon it um so we're taking it
further now with 2042 and that means
that this different seats in a vehicle
um have significantly more roles
available you can have a particular seat
in a tank for example that is a spotter
seat
so your friend who's in the spotter seat
uh his or her job is to actually just
spot
um and there's there's of course it's
kind of a given
with cutting-edge technology and modern
hardware 360 degree
turn turrets for gunner i've missed it
it's wonderful that it's back uh and
it's really cool and there's there's
many other ones there's like anti-air
seats uh just of course the driver seats
and the gun receipts and different types
of gunner seats grenade launchers rocket
launchers
um there's even one vehicle that can
deploy mines on the go so it's perfect
if someone is pursuing you and
chasing you and you just put down some
mines on the go and you see them blow up
behind you
yeah maybe i mean we give it a big
frostbite upgrade we got a new physics
you know sub engine as part of that so i
think that the like the level of skill
that's now in the vehicles just kind of
driving the transport vehicles
controlling the tanks it's really cool
uh it's a level of kind of you know
physicality we haven't had in our
previous games and a level of control
that's
you know completely new it just it just
feels better to maneuver and better to
drive
and it's just it's more fun to take them
off some you know take off some sweet
jumps as you say
um but i mean the cool thing about
vehicles
which i also want to mention is kind of
like when you're playing battlefield
even if you're not a vehicle player just
being around
vehicles is awesome so even if you want
to play infantry and you're running
around an orbital for example and you're
you're on your way to the rocket and
you're an idiot like me as you know you
just try to run across open space
you're seeing two transport vehicles you
know just coming around the band and
then being engaged in a high speed fight
just in front of you
you're a part of that moment even if
you're not driving the actual vehicle
and that's also the those things we call
battlefield moments they're
sometimes they're big and they're
bombastic but just having
that moment happen in front of you looks
like it's a scripted moment almost but
it's two players just ducking it out in
two vehicles
having that uh it's just it's just
such a great addition that that that you
you only get in battlefield basically
and it really does make all the
difference in the world when you
you're rising out above the stadium on
hourglass and you're looking out across
the distance to just see
jets and tanks just all over the place
it's it's great for battlefield players
who've been playing this franchise for a
long time
oh yeah for sure um but we really are
just scratching the surface here
there's so much more to tell you on the
road ahead of course the 22nd of july
will be there at ea play to show the
next experience that's coming to 2042
and then later hazard zone and we're
keeping pretty tight lips on
both of these experiences so far but
what can we tell people about hazard
zone
what can they expect from it yeah hazard
zone is
really something that's taking kind of
the super powers or dice the balfour
formula to a new level it's a high
stakes
squad based uh experience it's not your
battle royale that you might be
expecting is something new and a bit
more contemporary i'd say
i'd say so um but i think it is
important to call out that this is not a
battle royale mode
um it's something that we're building
for battlefield it's something that
we're building that is ours
but it is really built on those
mechanics those
high stakes mechanics that really builds
tension
as you play and gets you like you know
those sweaty palms moments when you're
just like
but it's also then you know combined
with squad play i mean we are a squad
based
team play shooter and i'd say there's no
other space
um within 2042 where the choices you
make in terms of
what i choose to bring and what my
friends choose to bring what specialist
is my friend playing
what weapon is my friend playing what
gadgetry is my friend playing
that has such an incredibly high
importance in hazard zone when you're
playing this game so really really tight
squad play
really really tight communication is
important
um and then built around those that
tension builder high stakes type of
gameplay
so uh super excited to talk about this
yeah as we
uh when we're allowed to talk about it
in a bit in a bit
soon um and another part of this
experience which again
we we've started to talk a little bit
about is live service yeah
we we've we definitely are happy to talk
to people about what our approach is so
far so
what what have we saying so far so most
importantly
we want to make sure that we take the
best of the learnings we've had from the
likes of
say battlefield 5 where we can keep all
our players together yeah i mean
that's a big big decision we made really
early on in the project we don't want to
split our community in any way when it
comes to gameplay content so all of the
new locations will head out to imported
live service
you know free for everyone as part of
that and then we are introducing a
battle pass as part of our seasons we've
announced
four seasons as part of the first year
every season will also come with a
specialist
the battle pass system has two tiers the
free tier and the premium tier
and all of your gameplay hardware you'll
of course find in the free tier and then
the premium tier cosmetics and stuff you
can use to express yourself across
vehicles weapons and your specialists
yeah we'll have plenty more to say on
that
before we launch the game but stick
around we're going to take another look
at our gameplay trailer that we debuted
this past week at the xbox showcase
and when we return we'll be back with
more of the gang from across dice to
chat some more about battlefield 2042
incoming
attention all squads the russian troops
are falling back
do whatever you can to secure the sector
we push them back but not far enough do
not let them regroup
oh
[Music]
what
we need to get away
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think i'm ever going to get
bored of watching that trailer
but welcome back folks um as promised we
are joined now
by more of the gang from dice uh joining
us we have marie busgard grenland
associate producer on 2042
nicole lee senior game designer and
ferris masmar associate design director
how we doing gang
you realize this is the largest
collection of dice employees that has
happened now
in what close to a year and a half oh
it's been north of a year right
i think we met yesterday oh it was a
thrilling experience humans in the real
flesh that can build
video games even it's pretty rad yeah
did you have it on your game dev bingo
cards that you go back to making video
games in your bedrooms was
was that something you expected on your
career past something that we dreamed
about
maybe
[Laughter]
but yeah it's been a challenging
experience but at the same time it
showed like a lot of positives of how
the team connected to each other and
that sort of stuff and it's really
nice to be together again actually like
more of these guys heads
it's kind of interesting actual head
yeah
3d rendered in real time yeah yeah
high definition yeah 4k and all of that
um
we obviously just got to take another
look at that incredible
gameplay trailer that we showed off this
weekend um
your favorite parts of this because
there's so much cool stuff happening in
there
a lot of which is is work that you guys
helped to to shape up but
but marie like when you're watching that
trailer back this weekend like
what was the big thing that got you
smiling just seeing it happen there in
the big screen
i think just seeing it all come together
as a like game
really like that you can experience for
real uh i think the last couple of
months we have been
working on this game so tirelessly and
just seeing it now
just come together to the experience
that we kind of envisioned from the
beginning it's just so thrilling
yeah nicole did you have a favorite part
looking back on it it's really when
you're seeing
all those vehicles in action at last
because
previously whenever you're looking at
one of these kinds of trailers you'll
just go okay there's a bunch of
infantry there's some scattered vehicle
action and this time you have them
out there in strength and then you're
seeing all that crazy action going on
from high altitudes all the way to the
ground fighting is just
intense and that's what i feel
battlefield really is
ferris your favorite part for me it was
the tornado actually because i remember
when it was first
pitched we saw it on the presentations i
was like i'm not sure we'll be able to
build this but then when we actually
see it in software and now we're able to
talk about it and show it to people it's
it's very exciting
and it really is exciting as well
because i like we had your story from
earlier on dan about how it just it
changed the gameplay experience
but i mean we all play our play tests
you know really regularly and
it is crazy just how many different
stories we each kind of have
about you know these big kind of events
that happen on
the maps like oscar you you've certainly
enjoyed your time wing suiting around in
that thing
yeah i mean i for some reason i start
every single morning the same way so get
up early
download the latest build i then take my
kids to school and daycare and then i
sit down and i enjoy
a breakthrough round with ai and there's
always like a good five ten minutes of
just wing shooting for no apparently
more than that wing sitting it's just
pretty rad
love it um let's get back into some more
of the details then that we were
chatting about just before we watched
that trailer
um so ferris we were chatting earlier on
today
about progression because we've we've
obviously taken
lots of different approaches to it over
the years but with this we've really
tried to think
about the best possible player
experience haven't we
especially now with the with the new
move towards the
specialist system where the players can
actually equip
the their weapons all over the different
characters we moved a little bit away
from the class system
this allowed us to actually have more
streamlined progression where the player
can
progress all of their characters
technically at the same time because
they're unlocking hardware that they can
use
on all of them and they're unlocking
vehicles that they can use for all of
their specialists
so this helped us a lot uh looking at it
looking a way to streamline it make it
uh more engaging for the uh players
because that really is like the
the best part of the experience really
now because when we rank up
previously you've as a player targeted
that one
thing i'm going to sit on assault or sit
on an assault rifle class and
try and work towards that next unlock
but now you find your you know you're
unlocking new equipment
it's making you change the way you think
about some of the specialists you
maybe haven't played already making you
think
but if i use this now with this
specialist this changes the experience
up quite a lot doesn't it
yeah it's it's easier to make the jump
um
like like we mentioned earlier we've
seen in data from previous games that
like
you know when when people have maxed out
a particular class and they will they
they
it's time to maybe jump to to another
class to play something you're like yeah
but i don't want to use this weapon type
so i'm i'm just not going to um but this
time around with it with the new
openness and and the more approach to a
sandboxy
notion of the entire systems um
it's easier for for people to to kind of
just jump around and test different
things and if you
really have a weapon you're proficient
with and you like you can
bring that weapon with you to any of the
specialists you can just try it out
um and i think that just lowers the um
the threshold of trying out different
things in general
yeah it's certainly been that way for me
i mean i've exclusively avoided the
recon class because i'm just a
potato sniper but yet
historically we've had so many cool
gadgets and and functions available in
that kind of class and role
like nicole has it changed up your kind
of play style when you're interacting
with the different specialists
i i think absolutely and especially i
always like to talk about casper
when you've got a motion sensor down
there and you know there's someone in
the area your situational awareness
changes
and you can play it both ways right on
one hand you can say i'm gonna take a
shotgun
oh wait recons don't normally carry
shotguns i got a shotgun now or
smg and you just go in and you start
clearing up a room and then
alternatively if you're like
up on the purge somewhere and you say
someone might go in the elevator over
there but i've got a really good perch
right now with my sniper rifle
uh you just go oh there's a motion
sensor telling me there's someone behind
you can solve a problem so it's really a
different approach to
solving these kinds of combat puzzles
that just show up from time to time and
i think that's a huge change really and
it's such a cool
world as well that we get to play in
like we were chatting about it a lot
earlier on talking about in
relation to our maps and in relation to
the you know the the characters and
the way that we're kind of approaching
storytelling in this game because
this is new for us uh we've obviously
had story and reasons to go to
places in the past in past games but
like how's it being now developing a
battlefield game where we're telling so
much of this story of
no pats in this world that you know
we're inheriting in 2042
as designers and producers like is it
changing your approach to
the content that you guys make i think
because this time around we also
uh are trying to enrich the uh because
we don't have a single player campaign
in 2042
we're infusing the lore of the world via
the
specialist and via the surrounding
elements that you have in the world
and we're going to take that even
further during the live service so it
made us
approach growing the lore of the
universe in a very
different way that is embedded in the in
the gameplay you're naturally
exposed to the lore of the world as
you're playing the game
getting understanding kind of why you're
there as well and what the
specialist that you're playing as why
they're fighting is also quite
interesting
yeah because these no pats the
non-patriated they're they're each
fighting for something aren't they
because
i mean whilst this is it can look like a
bleak world there's there's definitely a
lot of
optimism in these notepads and
everything they're fighting for yeah we
i mean early on in the concert we talked
about the notion of hope and the notion
of
purpose and a notion that's really
filled with change and i think we
we've gotten the chance now to talk
about some of the backstory to this game
but that's just really the tip of the
iceberg
this is kudos to everyone in the
narrative team you know back home
there's just so much work that's gone
down into the no patch to the locations
and as we kind of jump into a live
service now there's a lot of secrets we
haven't talked about so far
you know behind all this world so we're
looking forward to taking our place on a
journey
to explore more about what's actually
led up to 2042 and what's next
yeah um it is really exciting this story
by the way you'll hear lots more
about it from us before we go on to
launch the game
when you're looking back then at 2042
and all the work we've done so far
because
i mean while it's it's crazy to think
that this last week really has been the
first time players are learning about it
we've been living with this secret now
for quite a while like now that we've
reached this kind of checkpoint for us
as a team when you're looking back like
what's the big thing that you're so
proud of and so excited for players
uh to be able to get to play
i i mean there's so much to really talk
about when it comes to this but i'm
always talking about
the setting right because you are really
dealing with that kind of
modern era where there's so many
opportunities and when you have new tech
coming in you can bring that all
together
and when i talk about tech i'm not just
talking about military hardware it's
about
all the other stuff you have on the
processing side we are able to deliver
this in the game
and you're just having this experience
that people across different
platform generations are able to enjoy
and that's something i find that's truly
truly exciting and then empowered like
with the new tech as well like we were
able to build
maps on a bigger scale than before that
we were able to
add all this like dynamic elements to
them that is quite
interesting and then combined with the
all the elements you mentioned and the
hardware we brought in like the sandbox
has expanded in a very very
interesting ways for us that maybe we
didn't even foresee it to
go to these lengths when we first
started actually yeah because
it's amazing like because daniel you and
the team obviously worked so hard to
try and map out the experience we're
going to build but it's quite incredible
really that
the instant we start more potential
opens up for us and
yeah we really must have evolved so much
since that original concept when we sat
down those years
oh yeah yeah you know it's involved
quite quite some
um but i think that's also the nature of
battlefield right we always have
we also have kind of like a notion of
like okay these are the tools that we're
gonna give you
but we know from experience that every
single game we release
there's just there's combinations that
we haven't really thought of there's
things that people are gonna do
that we haven't really thought of and
like sometimes it becomes takes some
extreme
um some extreme cases but most of the
time it's actually just
part of that sandbox fun the mix
battlefield battlefield
so i'm excited for for 2042 coming out
and actually getting in the hands of the
players because there's i think there's
there's more opportunities in these
games to find these kind of
crazy moments that we necessarily didn't
find in our testing
um that people just gonna find when they
play uh so i'm looking forward to that
see what uh what everyone can
kind of come up with basically i mean
it's it's crazy as well because
even though there's so many of us from
across dice here in stockholm here and
again with there's so many more of us
just sat at home kind of watching this
live with you guys right now
um but it isn't just dice that's helping
to work and
and shape this new era of battlefield of
course we've got
so many more teams including dice la
you've got some really exciting stuff to
show
us at ea play oscar yeah i mean we first
mentioned now we have folks in stockholm
in you know gothenburg and guilford and
la and you know folks across
all over the world actually across
electronic arts you're helping building
battlefield 2042 but the stuff that's
actually getting built out of the isola
is quite special the team joined our big
team meeting i think we broke some can
assume world record lots of folks were
actually in that meeting
and they got the chance to show the
latest update from that experience
i think our shot kind of exploded the
team's super pumped and we're just
looking forward to july 22nd at ea play
live where we get to chance to show the
world
what the dice delay team have been
working on it's quite special i'd say
it's going to be good i'm big time
excited for what our friends at dice la
have to show you at ea place so make
sure you stick it in your diaries
july 22nd i promise if you're watching
this
you don't want to miss it so marie
nicole ferris
the boss man dan it's been great seeing
you
and chatting to you today and of course
taking everyone a bit behind the scenes
on all the work that's being done on
2042. we really do have so much more to
show you
subscribe bang on the notifications and
for me and the gang
working across 2042 stay safe stay
healthy
and we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you